what am i like in high school well um
i'm an average student um b is in c's
i have friends that are really close and
and uh try to keep that a sacred thing
much like rebecca and eno do in the film
how can you stand all these
some people are okay but mostly i just
feel like poisoning everybody
what's rebecca like she's a pretty
intelligent girl been sort of quiet her
whole life she's our own person
i don't know i think there's a little
bit of init and rebecca and everyone
she's um quite the character she's
always been
sort of not your average girl she's a
bit crazy
she's very like scattered you know one
minute she's off doing one thing and the
next like
boom she's completely on a whole another
track you know and i don't think she
really kind of knows what she wants
we have to get together this summer yeah
that'll definitely happen i mean um
enid is uh really out there but also
very insecure and
i think both characters are quite
insecure and uh
that's why they find such a bond within
each other so which
one i'm more like i can't really say i
don't know if i relate to either of them
i totally totally hate you the director
like ordered us today
he was like yeah you and scarlet should
really you know get together so like
okay she's pretty mature you know she's
from new york which means she's an adult
at the age of three
so me and steve buscemi argue all the
time that uh that nobody's ever gonna
work after this film
of course which is not true i love
this place it's so um i don't know
you know um funky
i think ghost world is when you're
like walking down the street or
something or you're on a train or
whatever
you just think like wow this is such a
it's so surreal it's such a strange
world that we're living in today
i think it's like when you have moments
like that where you kind of look around
and
you think like wow this seems not unreal
i think that's really what
the ghost world is but who knows
well i'm still in high school i'm going
into my senior year
i enjoy school when i'm learning things
about things that i'm interested in
which is kind of rare i think in high
school you know you get out of high
school and you're just like wow
thrown into the real world what do i do
[Music]
now